[MUSIC PLAYING]
NETO MARIN: Well,
we are here today
to explain how you can reach
billions of devices using
the Google system and,
of course, connected
through the Google
Cloud Platform.
So before we can start on some
deep dive on how you can extend
your service, your application
for the Google Assistant,
we would like to give
you a rough introduction
about the Google Assistant,
right, the actions on Google.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Totally.
Just in case you
haven't actually
used Google Assistant--
oh, can you hear me?
Sweet.
So just in case you haven't
used Google Assistant,
which I'm assuming
everyone has, hopefully--
there might be one person--
Google Assistant is all
about the conversation
that users could
have with Google.
You could say something
like, hey G, get this done.
Hey, G, remind me this.
I'm using the term
"Hey G" because I
don't want to actually activate
my phone nor your phones.
So it's a way that
users can talk to Google
and be more productive
in their day.
And the way that we do that
is by having over a billion
devices.
NETO MARIN: Yeah, exactly.
For example, during
many days, you surely
interact with different
devices, right?
When you wake up, you
already pick up your phone
from your nightstand.
And then when
you're driving, you
want to hear something
during this day.
Or even the you're
running, or you
can use one of the
headphones, for example,
with the Google Assistant.
So across the day, you are
using different devices.
And I'm pretty
sure that you want
to reach the users around this
day, right, along this journey.
So we can offer your content
not only on your website,
on your smartphone.
So we can extend across
[INAUDIBLE] across surfaces,
right?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Totally.
And it's not just devices.
It's also different languages.
So Google Assistant
is available in
multiple different languages.
That way, we're
meeting the users
where they're at in
the language that's
most comfortable
for them as well.
So we spent a lot
of time building
out these different
locales and languages
so that we could provide
the best service for users.
NETO MARIN: Yes.
For example, as
you can notice, I'm
not an English native speaker.
And of course, if
I had the choice
to talk in Brazilian
Portuguese with my assistant,
it would be great.
Because then
sometimes, I don't need
to keep translating in my
mind simple things like, turn
the lights on.
Because it sounds
simple, but imagine
you're already talking
English for the full day.
I want to just chill
out at my house
and I don't like to keep
talking in English sometimes.
Or even I have children.
They have five and seven years.
They're learning English yet.
So they prefer to
interact in Portuguese.
And imagine.
You can reach, for
example, we are
talking about probably the most
populous country in the world--
Brazil, India, UK, Spanish.
So you have a lot of
options of language.
So in Spanish, you
can talk with all
the Latin American countries.
So in that way, you
can make your action
available across many countries.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Totally.
Which is cool to be like, yeah,
Google Assistant does that,
but what does that mean
for us as developers?
Like, what can I do with this?
And this is where I get
really excited because we
can use all those
billion devices
in these different languages
to really expose our content
to other users as well.
And so I'd like to start off
with just some terminology.
Because we use the same
logo for Google Assistant,
which is a conversation
between Google and users.
And then there are
the actual devices.
That's the hardware that exists.
And Actions on Google
is the platform
that allows developers to
extend the Google Assistant
experience.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
I'd like to explain
this picture.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Exactly.
NETO MARIN: For example, I
have an Android development
background and full stack
development background.
So at the beginning,
it took me time
to understand where the
components are fitting
together.
So for example, here in
the Google Assistant,
you can imagine this as the
web or the Android platform,
where all the apps
or your web apps
live, where is the
actions on Google.
Sorry-- the devices that have
it working, like your phone.
And the apps are the actions.
So it's just a
new name for apps.
It's like instead of
saying I'm developing
app, an application
for Google Assistant,
we're developing actions.
Because we believe
that you're not
developing only the
experience of running an app,
but much more.
You are interacting
as an action.
You are running an action
using the Google Assistant.
So I like to establish
the comparison
if you want to keep in mind.
Google Assistant's
your platform.
Actions on Google's your apps.
And devices are your
smartphones, or your browser.
It depends on where
you compare to.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Definitely.
So Actions on Google is just
the platform in which developers
can build applications-- or
actions that we call it within
our world--
to expose that content and
to have that functionality.
So how does it all work?
So we're going to start
off on the right hand side.
Imagine Neto speaking this.
He's saying something like,
OK, G, talk to Personal Chef.
It's a made up
action that we made.
And so what happens there is
the device hears the keyword,
grabs the audio, and sends that
audio over to Google Assistant.
Google Assistant will
translate that audio to text.
We're going to use our own
natural language processing.
We're going to use
the user's preference.
We do our own machine learning
ranking, as well as the user
profile, to figure out
what does Neto actually
want when he says that?
And because he explicitly said
the name of an action that
exists, what's
going to happen is
Google Assistant is going
to ping my action's back end
and go, hey, someone wants
to talk to your action.
NETO MARIN: Exactly.
And this is the cool point,
because, for example,
in this first part, you can--
since the beginning, you can
handle all the communication
with your service.
So if you have, for example,
premium service, premium
entitlements, or you would like
to check the person is logged
in or not, you can
start right away
from the first interaction.
So because the Google
Assistant, in this case,
it's working more as a
bridge between the user
and your application.
It's like you take your
phone, open the launcher,
and selecting one app is
what you are doing here.
You are saying to
access that app--
this action, in this case.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Yeah, definitely.
Because after that,
if you notice,
Google Assistant doesn't do much
after it makes the connection.
After that, it's all on us.
So we create the
response we want to give,
and we give that response in
a text form, in a JSON format.
And we send it over
to Google Assistant.
Google Assistant will then will
translate that text to speech,
and then send the audio
over to the device
and actually respond
back to Neto.
NETO MARIN: Yes, exactly.
And the cool stuff you
might be thinking like, OK,
so on my back end, I
have to do, for example,
a bunch of natural
language processing
stuff to understand
what the user said
and then identify
what the user wants.
Not many work, right?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
Users are unique and different.
I know for myself, if you
were to ask my partner,
he would definitely
contest that I'm not
the most articulate person,
especially when it's things
that I want and my needs.
And let me put in my password.
So then in processing users--
NETO MARIN: Yes.
For example, in
this case, what we
are saying that you
don't need to implement
your own natural language
processing to handle
different accents,
different languages.
We have a tool for
you to do that.
It's Dialogflow.
And please raise
the hand who already
knows what Dialogflow is.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Sweet.
Dozen.
NETO MARIN: So basically,
it's like intent matching
[? and intent ?] [? reaction. ?]
So Dialogflow is doing all
the work for you in terms of
identifying words the user
said, the intent, or what
the user wants you to do.
And then you match exactly
to the part of her code.
And this is cool
because, for example, you
don't need to have
different back ends
for different languages.
We're going to go through
this on other examples.
You can have your only
one single back end
that you handle all the
requests because everything
would be handled--
in terms of language and
processing-- by Dialogflow.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yes.
So where does that leave within
our kind of flow of data?
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: So
that lives, actually,
between the Google
Assistant and your back end.
And so it lives
actually right here.
And what Dialogflow
is going to do,
it's going to get that raw
text of the user's utterance,
and it's going to use
its own natural language
processing to figure
out what do they
mean when they say a statement,
and then try to match it
with predefined
functionalities, as a developer,
we have defined.
And if it doesn't
match with anything,
we have a default
fallback intent,
which I like to think as
the else statement of all
my intents.
And it will be
captured through there.
And so Dialogflow just
sits right between.
And then it hits
our code going, hey,
they're hitting this part of
your function, this function.
And here are any
of the parameters
that you have asked me
to send to you as well.
And then at that point,
we just make our queries
to our database, do our
jazz, create the response,
and then send that
back to Dialogflow.
Dialogflow to Google Assistant.
Google Assistant translates
that text to speech.
And then that audio
gets sent to the device.
NETO MARIN: And this is
less than milliseconds.
So we don't have to worry
about overhead timing.
Because when the
user asks something,
you have kind of eight
seconds to reply.
So if you don't reply
in eight seconds,
the connection will
be closed as time out.
Because, of course, we
don't want to have actions
listen to you all the time.
So it will be closed
in eight seconds.
And you might think, OK, you
have Assistant, Dialogflow,
my back end, reading
data, returning this
all the way around.
Yeah, it will take less
then a few milliseconds.
So you can focus
on your own code.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Cool.
So we wanted to talk
about-- seeing that there's
some people who have
used Dialogflow,
we really wanted to talk
about localizing it.
Because it's one thing
to build an action,
especially in your
own native language.
You build it.
You're like, this is awesome.
It has all the functionality.
It's doing what I want.
And now the next thing
is, how do I expose this
to so many other people?
Because it's on the
billion devices.
But if somebody is
at their own home
and they're only
speaking one language,
you won't have access to them.
So what we did for this
particular action is for GDG,
which I believe
they were talking
about that in the talk prior,
about Google Developer Groups.
And so this is a project
that I've been building out
where a Google Developer
Group organizer can just
connect to their meetup API.
And it has a fully
functioned action
that will provide
information like when's
the next meetup, when's
the last meetup, who's
the organizer, how
many people are there.
And it's super easy
for our GDGs to set up.
And so the first thing I did
to make it localized was--
let's see.
Next-- was, of course,
the way that we have our--
I'm using Node.js because
we have our client library
in a language in JavaScript.
And so have an index.js file.
And I had all my code and
all my responses there.
And so the first thing
I needed to do in order
to localize my action was I
needed to actually pull out
all the responses.
And so I just separate
it, have all my responses
in the other file, and I
pulled on it whenever I wanted.
This really helped me
think about the responses
of my action in big categories.
Because I had defined,
this is the greeting.
This is the greeting
for new users
versus the greeting
of returning users,
which is naturally
going to be different.
Because when I first met
Neto, I had to go, hey, Neto,
I'm Jessica.
I'm from Calexico.
This is kind of my background.
I gave him a [INAUDIBLE]
the first time I meet him.
But the 10th time I meet
him, I just go, hey, Neto,
and that's it.
And so your actions want to
have that flexibility too.
And so by pulling
out your responses,
you have to kind of
think about what you
want to label the responses.
After that, because you're
going to have that pulled out,
you're going to want to have
that even further separated,
where you have a
locales directory.
And in there, you have your
files for every single language
using the same skeleton of your
JSON of your primary language,
which this one was in English.
And so that way, when you're
using a client library,
you can figure out which
language it's working with.
So that's the second step I did.
After that, I used I18N, pulled
that in, as well as Moment.
And what I had to do was just
do some configuration going,
hey, this is where my
locales are going to be.
And these are the fallbacks of
the different languages that I
might not have predefined.
So one of them is for Spanish.
And so we have Spanish,
which is ES419.
And then we also have
Spanish, which is ES-ES.
So 419 means it's Latin America.
ES-ES means that
it's in Spain, which
is very different Spanishes.
I'm treating them the same.
So I'm just saying, go to my
same Spanish file and use that.
But you can have further
granularity within that
as well.
So that's the next thing I did.
And then within my
code, I just had
to do a little bit
of refactoring.
And so this is my
welcome intent.
And so what's happening here
is that when my user activates
the action, it will greet them.
And so first thing
that happens is
I will localize
the conversation.
I will figure out,
where is the user from?
What is their locale,
like the language
they're using, which I get from
the conversational object that
gets passed back and
forth between the user
and me as a developer.
So I localize it.
And then I do some funny
jazz about suggestion tips.
Don't worry about that.
And then I have an
if statement asking
if I've seen that user before.
And if I have seen
them, I'm going
to give them a message
of the welcome back text.
And so you can see I'm using
I18N double underscore,
passing in that string of
the name of the response.
And then it creates
that message for me
in the appropriate language.
And then it will send
it using the conv.ask--
oh, you can't see that.
Let me go on the mouse.
Maybe you can see it there.
Then we do-- can
we see this mouse?
Yeah?
Maybe?
Thumbs up, people can see.
Thank you.
And then you do it
here with conv.ask,
sending in that speech message.
And then the message
in text form.
I have two variations.
I have a message that's in
the audio and message that
is in just text format
because my audio text actually
has natural line
breaks that I've put in
to make it sound more natural.
And I've actually
messed with the grammar.
And so instead of asking
questions with a question mark,
I'm asking questions
with a period.
Because it changes how the
audio is heard as well.
And so I did that
for every language,
tweaking the grammar slightly.
I did ask for a lot of
help from co-workers.
I asked a lot of help
from Neto to translate it
into Portuguese.
So thank you so much.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
Imagine, for example, sometimes
you on this [INAUDIBLE] side.
Imagine you're having
a conversation.
You're not building
voice comments.
They are different.
Voice comments are one thing.
Conversations are another thing.
So the point is, when you
are providing information
through voice, you need
sometimes to give more detail.
So for example, [INAUDIBLE]
to show some example
and give you some example,
from the visual perspective,
this example can be a
suggestion chip on the response.
But this won't be audible
for the user that doesn't
have a screen available.
So we need to give the
example in the speech part.
So this is the part
that's when you
have to separate the
speech between the text
and why you should
separate them.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Definitely.
And it was actually
really simple to localize
because literally, it's the
same code, except I've changed.
I've added this I18.N
double underscore.
And that's the only thing
once I pulled it out.
So making your action localized,
when it comes to the code part,
it's super easy.
The translation is a
little bit different.
So hopefully you have
really good friends
that speak multiple languages
to help you on that.
And we have another.
We have Sphero, which is
a fantastic IoT action.
NETO MARIN: Yeah, exactly.
One of our jobs, as developer
advocates, that I tend to say
is the most fun
job in the world,
we have to play with
some toys, some things
to study, right, to work.
This is the good part of
being a developer advocate.
And one challenge
is how you can--
imagine we are
building actions that
are going to run on devices.
But if you have a
startup or have an idea
and you are building
out hardware,
or any other
appliance, and you'd
like to make it work with
the Google Assistant, how
it can work?
We have, for example, the
home automation framework
with Home Graph.
But if it's not for
home automation,
if I have, like,
this robot, I want
to control this over voice.
And this idea came
when my daughter
saw this toy in a
shopping and I said,
yeah, looks like a nice toy.
But I had to find the
adult excuse to buy.
So I said, yeah,
maybe it's good so I
can try with Google Assistant.
And I realized it when she was
trying to control the Sphero.
And she started yelling at
this Sphero, stop, stop.
I said, cool.
I think it's easier to
control this over voice
than using a smartphone
or using a joystick.
OK, joystick could
be cool, but OK.
It's another thing.
So what I decided
to do is to showcase
how you could integrate
any kind of hardware.
So in this case specifically,
this little ball
is using BLI,
Bluetooth Low Energy.
So what I have here,
it's a Raspberry Pi.
And I'm using a Raspberry
Pi for the reason
that I want to have something on
my desk that I can try, deploy.
But you can, for example,
build an Android app that
connects through the Bluetooth
and run in your phone
if you want.
So here, we have a code that,
using the [INAUDIBLE] Node.JS
library, is sending comments
to control this Sphero.
And you know,
nothing new, right?
I'm just using the
pre-existing API
to send comments over Bluetooth
and make the ball run, right?
But if I say, OK, G, talk
to roll ball and hey,
go forward, go backward,
turn left, turn right.
So then we decide to do this.
I was planning to show live,
but the amount of Wi-Fi networks
here is interfering
with the Wi-Fi signal.
And to avoid other
surprises, I'm
going to show you
one of the videos.
We were testing this.
And OK, just play.
Is the volume?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Talk to roll ball.
- Sure.
[INAUDIBLE] test
version Roll Ball.
Let's go.
- Move short forward.
- OK.
- Move medium backward.
- Move left short.
- OK.
- Move right medium.
[END PLAYBACK]
NETO MARIN: So
all these comments
are going through Dialogflow.
I created some
entities to identify
the movement, like forward,
medium, forward, backward,
left, and right.
And I added this speed
component, like slow or fast,
to indicate how amount of
time should move in this case.
So of course, this
is a toy project.
The code will be soon
released on our GitHub
with a blog post
that's coming together.
But you can imagine this as
you are building appliance,
you're building
something cool, and you'd
like to control this using
the voice with the Assistant,
right?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
That's super cool.
So I know we only have,
like, 10 seconds left.
NETO MARIN: 10.
Yeah.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Just
want to do a shout out.
If you do build an action
and you go under Review,
it gets deployed on
production level,
you do get automatically
entered into our Actions
on Google community, which
means you get a cool shirt.
And then let me read this,
because I would say it wrong--
$200 of Cloud credits per month
for a year, which is great.
NETO MARIN: To run
your action background.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
That money could
be used to translate your
action using the Translate
API as well.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
And then this
is usually the photo that I
recommend to everyone to take.
If you're interested in
building for Actions on Google,
this contains all the cool links
and resources to start off.
So we highly recommend
to actually start off
using our Codelabs.
And so it's on the right hand.
It's the second one, Codelabs.
Go there.
Try our Codelabs.
That way you can
get your hands dirty
and build an action
for yourself.
NETO MARIN: And if you're
going to Google I/O,
please visit us there.
We'll be there all the days.
We'll have new Codelabs
coming for the Google I/O.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Ooh.
Teasers.
NETO MARIN: Yes.
We will be there.
And we will be here on the--
somewhere.
I think the [INAUDIBLE]
booth for some time.
We have some pins and nice swag.
So please, if you
have any questions,
we are happy to answer.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yes.
Thank you so much.
Appreciate it.
NETO MARIN: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]